5e fonda
[Applaudissements]
je suis laurent bonjour laurent je suis
très gentil vous avez l'air merci c'est
thierry toi que j'ai une moitié alors ça
va plus ou moins oui pourquoi pas dans
plus ou moins normalement je suis
endormi à 9 heures je dois chercher mes
mots en français
mais ces sites mais je vais y arriver
alors jane fonda vous êtes la fille de
henri fonda
oui la soeur de peter fonda oui la tante
de bridget fonda oui mais à part ça vous
êtes qui un jour vous êtes posé cette
question et la réponse est dans un livre
qui est publié chez plon et qui
s'appelle ma vie un livre qui est sorti
aux états unis sur le titre de my life
sofa marie jusque là et qui s'est vendu
là-bas pratiquement à un million
d'exemplaires sortie numéro un numéro un
comme d'habitude je sais pas j'avais le
film numéro 1 elle livre numéro en même
temps c'est pas mal ça
non j'ai patrie de man ce moment en moi
alors vous expliquer dans la préface de
votre livre jane que à 59 ans en 1996 le
troisième acte de votre vie s'ouvrait et
pour le réussir il fallait comprendre ce
qui s'était passé avant voilà et c'est
pour ça que vous avez fait ce livre et
en faisant ce travail en arrivant mais
60 j'avais réalisé que healy aline qui
traverse ma vie assez universel et si je
pouvais raconter honnêtement ça pouvait
aider les autres bien sûr et je crois
que j'avais réussi on apprend dès le
début du livre donc que votre mère vous
a légué les séquelles d'un traumatisme
dont elle avait été victime à l'âge de 8
ans elle avait été victime d'abus
sexuels d'un accordeur de piano qui
était la seule personne en fait qu'ils
étaient autorisés à rentrer dans sa
maison
oui parce que votre grand père était
très très très dur
il était schizophrène paranoïaque
alcoolique qui frappait ses enfants il
interdisait à tout le monde de rentrer
et l'accordeur de piano rentrer et
violent de votre mère à l'âge de huit
ans et ce traumatisme dont elle a été
victime
finalement vous en avez un petit peu
irrité non je ne savais pas que cette
crise est arrivée dans sa vie c'était
trois ans après j'ai commencé mon livre
que j'ai découvert ça et en le
découvrant
jet tours réalisés sur elle et je
pouvais le pardonner elle moi même aussi
quand une fille
violente est sexuellement elle perd
c'est ses repères elle porte une
culpabilité
malgré sa jeunesse est souvent haleine
pour son propre corps qui peuvent être
harry héritiers de par sa fille alors
vos parents se sont rencontrés en 1936
vous naissez en 1937
ça se passait pas très bien en train
votre père était et effroi colérique il
parlait peu vous dites dans ma vie
jamais parlé plus d'une demi heure avec
lui c'est vrai oui c'est assez universal
ouais vous avez vu le fait une maison de
la wii
ah bon alors ce personnage c'était mon
père et c'est c'est très commun alors
votre père avait avait des aventures et
un moment il a été question de divorce
entre vos parents et à ce moment là
l'état psychologique de votre mère s'est
dégradée elle a fini par se par se
suicider et vous quand vous êtes petit
on vous explique que c'est une une crise
cardiaque
oui mais en fait c'était pas ça du tout
j'ai appris un homme après casser ces
dlc trancher la gorge
oui oui vous l'avez appris en lisant le
journal oui vous avez quel âge 13 ans 13
ans un jour vous entendez votre père
vous dire que vous avez les jambes un
peu épaisses et s'avoue traumatise aussi
un c'est à dire qu'à partir de là vous
décidez quand vous mangez ensuite de
vous faire vomir jeu se faire de la
boulimie
alors accès il m'a fait croire que
j'étais grosse j'étais trop grosse ouais
faut faire gaffe à ce qu'on dit aux
enfants vous ça a duré quand même de
l'âge de 14 ans jusqu'à l'âge de 40 ans
ah oui et personne ne savait même les
hommes avec qui vous viviez ni mes
enfants
non c'est un maladie facile à cacher on
arrive en mai à l'eau le sens et c'est
assez commun pour des pour décrire je me
suis comment dirais-je désincarné vous
êtes je ne voulais rien à voir avec moi
corporellement salé c'est une vide et
j'ai rempli le vide avec des dates
addiction et puis c'était beaucoup plus
tard que j'ai commencé à me remplir à
revenir dans votre co sspt absolument
c'est ça oui alors quand vous êtes
mannequin à new york que l'adolescent
chez high line ford
vous prenez des cours avec lee strasberg
à l'actor's studio et et à ce moment là
vous vous bourrez n'ont fait ta mine de
diurétiques aussi cessé pour cesser pour
pas grossir toujours pour être comme il
faut aux yeux des autres oui alors votre
premier tournage de film ça s'appelle la
tête à l'envers
c'est un véritable cauchemar parce qu'à
l'époque justement toujours pour pour
avoir l'air on vous fait mettre des faux
seins on vous conseille de vous faire
refaire la mâchoire on veut vous
arracher les molaires enfin cesser c'est
terrible on a voulu vous former à une
image un peu l'idéal à ce moment là oui
et cette âme à ce moment là je me suis
dit bon c'est fini laurent les world je
ne veux plus mais j'avais besoin
d'argent donc je suis retourné et
finalement ça ça s'est bien terminé
c'est là que vous venez à paris en 1963
pour faire l'essai l'un le film de rené
clément avec alain delon et là vous
rencontrer roger vadim qui a été quand
même votre votre grand amour un dec en
2030 d'amour
même en première main forte à mots
voilés grand amour alors quand vous
l'aviez rencontré quelques années avant
57 vous dites dans votre bouquin que il
vous avez semblé un peu un prédateur
quel âge un peu un peu dangereux
oui et pourquoi vous vous jetez dans ses
bras quand vous revenez à paris en 63 le
lam que j'ai découvert deux ans trois
ans après était un nounours oui et on
n'est jamais seulement une chose ou
l'autre il avait un côté dangereux
les liaisons dangereux mais il avait un
côté très nounours très jantes et
surtout charmant et chantaient des
anciens chance en français qui m'a
s'amuser et il avait une fille nathalie
et chaque après-midi après il nous avons
fait l'amour
il sortait du lit pour aller la voir si
gentil et je me suis dit alors c'est un
homme qui est capable d'aimer ses
enfants c'est bien et je suis tombée
amoureuse
j'étais tombée amoureuse dans le lit je
dois dire oui c'est là aussi que j'ai
appris le français que j'ai oublié décor
la lumière leur retour alors au départ
vous êtes resté trois semaines sans
faire l'amour avec roger vadim que oui
il y avait un blocage c'était dû à quoi
je ne sais pas mais c'était assez
troublant mais en même temps je me suis
dit mais il est humain quand même c'est
pas super g
vous vous culpabiliser à l'époque vous
pensez que c'est est de votre faute mais
oui mais oui
encore aujourd'hui je suis sûr que c'est
il a réalisé que j'étais pas brigitte
bardot judicieux que c'est ça mais en
tous les cas il avait raison en tous les
cas quand vous commencez à faire l'amour
avec roger vadim pendant 48 heures vous
sortez pas du lit après ouais bah
c'était chaud la wii
vous êtes attraper oui je crois qu'on a
des images dans le problème c'est que
roger vadim joue au cours s'ils jouent
au casino et ils dilapident un petit peu
les 150000 dollars que votre mère vous
avez laissé en héritage un peu gigolo
quand même ils étaient ils avaient des
addictions addictions alcool langue
anglaise et je ne me rendais pas compte
à l'époque j'étais jeune on à la fin des
années soixante et un jour roger vadim
nous explique que sur le plan sexuel
il faut pas être bourgeois comme on
disait à l'époque il faut il faut faire
ce qu'on a envie de faire il faut avoir
une grande liberté sexuelle quoi voilà
et alors tout en étant avec vous il des
couches souvent un oui c'est vrai ouais
et la bm de la jalousie
je ne voulais pas être bourgeoise voilà
et je pensais je pensais que ce n'était
pas suffisant pour lui adore quelquefois
il a amené d'autres femmes mais un jour
il arrive à la maison c'est vrai avec
une superbe call girl de chez madame
claude et je suis pas je n'osais pas
dire non parce que j'avais peur qu'ils
me quitteras et sans lui je n'existerais
plus et ce qui est intéressant je suis
jane fonda quand même
j'étais je dépends des pas sur lui
financièrement sur le may cry ça je ne
pouvais pas je mettais ma voix insomnies
par peur qu'ils me quittera alors vous
êtes un truc dans le bouquin vous dites
parfois vous prenez l'initiative vous
même de ces partis à trois ou à quatre
agences et oui mais voilà vous dis je
bourgeois oui cela sonnait chez les
voisins
voilà ce que vous dites à l'époque
j'étais convaincu d'aimer ça est ce que
vous dites est un jeu bout juillet où
vous y preniez du plaisir franchement
parce que ce n'est pas on ne sait jamais
avec les femmes si elles le font c'est
pour faire plaisir au cou c'est assez
intéressant d'ailleurs de regarder une
autre femme faire avoir un orgasme
jamais vu ça personnellement non oui
sérieusement jane vous vous y prenez du
plaisir c'était pas uniquement je ne
sais pas je t'ai toujours ifrane et ce
qui est incroyable c'est que vadim fait
de vous qui ne vous n' est pas un sex
symbol avec un film culte qui est
barbarella
et là vous commencez à croire quand même
que vous êtes belle à ce moment-là vous
arrêter dans non mais j'aimais bien le
film après un prêt maintenant quand je
le vois je trouve très charmant oui
c'est génial
oui alors fait une carrière au cinéma
extraordinaire et puis vous faites un
enfant parce que vous avez besoin de
donner un sens à votre vie
ça vous suffit pas et là vous découvrez
le militantisme alors vous militez pour
les indiens d'amérique pour les black
panthers contre la guerre au vietnam
j'ai rencontré des gens qui vivaient au
delà de leurs même un des gens très
intelligents qui auraient pu être des
hommes d'affaires des femmes d'affaires
réussie dans le monde normal ils ont
décidé de l'appliquer leur talent pour
une chose qu en cause oui ça m'a
beaucoup impressionné je n'ai jamais
rencontré des gens comme ça avant a par
simone signoret oui c'est elle qui vous
a un petit peu mais dans tout ça ne
l'avait pas ou est ce vrai mais c'est
surtout le fait que j'étais à paris en
1968 enceinte avec ma fille enceinte
avec moi même
entouré par les français qui savaient
beaucoup mieux que moi que le vietnam
était un grande erreur et qui m'a
expliqué tout ça et puis les événements
de mai à youri sens et ça commençait à
me changer et c'était vers simone que je
suis allé pour à boire mais
weiss le conseil des conseils merci
jamais vu de son gaz
que c'est beau c'est le même chose chez
les hommes sauf que c'est plus compliqué
et plus merveilleux chez nous pourquoi
parce que on a des des organes de
commande et hongun des organes plus
complexes qui peu à peu se répéter
plusieurs fois dans l'escaut bout
s
je fais des des fils du théâtre et je
dis des bêtises à la télé moi aussi la
mémoire on me paye pour ça mais vous
doute à tort non ah bon auteur conteur
et puis à ce que scénario de choses
comme ça j'ai une petite épicerie à
château mais bon là je démarre c'est pas
encore ça mais non meilleur sur l'ag
patrick jane fonda sais je sais pas si
tu te rends compte mais incroyable il
faut que tu donnes ton dvd là parce que
oui oui mon film je vais vous offrir mon
fils d'accord très beau film très
vraiment
bien
alors jen oui votre action aux militants
donc redouble quand vous rencontrez le
deuxième grand amour de votre vie après
roger l'a dit tom hayden et là vous vous
partez au vietnam vous partez à un oeil
et vous fait une faute vous fait
photographier à côté d'une batterie
antiaérienne nord-vietnamienne et vous
donnez l'impression quand on voit la
photo de tirer sur des avions américains
et ça n'est pas le cas et je regrette
pas le voyage
je regrette ce photo je suis allé là
pour exposer les mensonges de nixon kid
qui voulait que en croit qu'ils qu'il
était en train de terminer la guerre ce
qui n'était pas le cas
et quand ils vous prennent cette photo
vous leur dites ne va publier panne a
publié par vous vous sentez vous sentez
ils l'ont publié ça vous a fait beaucoup
de torts et vous dit que c'est une
erreur mais qui pèse encore lourd oui
sur votre conscience aujourd'hui ans et
l'époque on vous appelle gentreau hanoi
et c'est un scandale aux usa vous avez
vous avez beaucoup de gens contre vous à
ce moment là en amérique nom des gens
d'extrême droite
oui encore aujourd'hui ils ont créé une
mite d'un autre jeune qui n'a rien à
voir avec moi mais ça leur sert pour
porter leur idéologie d'extrême droite
alors en 1978 vous avez une vie
extraordinaire quand même parce que là
vous découvrez un cours de remise en
forme d'un genre nouveau
un sorte de d'aérobic un petit peu on
peut on peut dire et vous décidé de
monter une affaire avec avec le créateur
lénine le créateur de ça pour financer
les activités politiques de tom hayden
il ça va se révéler cette histoire une
véritable poule aux oeufs d'or vous
allez y ait énormément d'argent en
faisant ce à quoi c'est l'organisation
qui qui qui a reçu beaucoup d'argent au
cou d'orsoni et il ya beaucoup de gens
encore aujourd'hui aux états unis
et ailleurs dans le monde qui quand ils
me voient et pense à la robic weppes à
la militante et vous avez tellement
tellement de vies différentes peut faire
les deux on peut militer en faisant de
l'aérobie n'ont fait un livre sur cette
méthode d'aérobic qui reste deux ans
numéro un des ventes qui est traduit en
50 langues et qui est vendu à 17
millions d'exemplaires c'est c'est
colossal
hilton hayden à ce moment là votre votre
mari vis vis ça très mal votre succès
non pas pourquoi non il n'y avait pas ça
il n'aimait pas ça il commence à boire
il commençait avant ça le problème
toujours sur desalle que c'est que
j'avais trop je me suis trouvé avec un
homme qui ne buvaient pas je venais à
musulmans non merci
à ce moment là donc tom hayden
effectivement on n'est pas très contents
de tous à votre vie de couple tourner un
petit peu au fiasco
et là vous dites je me fait refaire les
seins et on vous en avait honte en fait
vous avez enlevé d'ailleurs quelques
années plus tard vous avez enlevé
oui les implants en silicone oui ils
sont où d'ailleurs je me demande
j'ai demandé au médecin de melay
d'années pour que je puisse les mettre
sur l'homme je menais chi minh et oui
vous pouvoir dire au revoir
cette partie de ma vie fanning
un long hommage alors comment mais comme
ça si vous voulez oui mais je sais pas
j'étais très malheureuse le mariage ne
marchait plus et jetez trait à ce moment
dans ce genre de carl de 10 à très
vulnérable à la société de consommation
je voulais je croyais que ces j'avais
des dessins comme ça je pouvais être
bien quoi
et j'avais tort change rien
d'extraordinaire avec vous quand même
c'est qu'au milieu de tout ça vous
produisez
la maison du lac qui vaudra à votre père
son premier oscar cinq mois avant sa
mort et c'est là vous voulez retrouver
en fait in extremis
oui j'ai acheté le pièce c'était une
pièce à broadway et je sache en croyant
que ça pouvait lui apporter sur l'oscar
et je vais raison et en plus je pouvais
travailler avec lui avant sa mort dans
un film qui était un peu parallèle à nos
rapports dans la vie je pouvais lui dire
des choses que je ne pouvais pas dire
dans la diversité
il ya un moment de vérité quand il a les
larmes aux yeux dans le film en fait ce
sont ces puces et du cinéma ou si c'est
la villa à ce moment là oui c'est très
beau ça c'était le cinéma d'ici
c'était très émouvant
je me sens très recommandé sa béni oui
oui je me sens très béni que j'ai pu
faire ce film pour lui travailler avec
lui dans ce sens ça c'est moi cinq mois
avant sa mort ça n'arrive pas souvent
dans la bd des filles quoi surtout que
vous aviez deux oscars lisant sur la
cheminée
on continue mais ça oui qu'est ce qui
vous a dit votre père dans le ces
derniers mois vous a raconté des choses
sur eux sur sur votre mère sur votre
enfant il ne parlait pas on peut pas
arriver à des choses à la fin de ma vie
qu'on n'a pas pu le faire dans avant non
mais c'est moi qui pouvais lui dire je
t'aime je sais que tu as fait ton mieux
de tant mieux en fait le départ henry
fonda il travaillait dans une banque
et c'est là c'est la mère de marlon
brando qui l'a branché sur le théâtre
c'est absolument incroyable
oui c'est l'employé de banque henry
fonda j'ai appris ça dans le bouquin le
lendemain de l'annoncé de votre divorce
avec tom hayden ted turner vous appelle
le magnat des médias américains ted
turner le fondateur de cnn
alors vous le rencontrez au début c'est
le choc des mondes quand vous le
rencontrez c'est très drôle dans le
livre parce que oui à un moment le mec
qui dit il sont ensemble au restaurant
il faut que j'évite danger moi c'est
très très classe comme très classe petit
plus c'est gros texan côte pendant les
dîners il est allé aux toilettes ce x 1
et je me suis dit bon les côtés y no man
oui
bien sûr et puis quelques mois après je
suis allé avec lui à son rang charmante
anna et 60 mille hectares est il quand
ils me conduisait pour me montrer le
terrain chaque cinq minutes il sortait
peu se pisser alors là j'ai vu que
c'était pas la cocaïne c'était le vrai
mais si mais si
oui oui quoi l'argent n'achète pas tôt
ouais m'enfin bon ce qu'il faut savoir
quand même c'est que vous découvrez que
c'est un bon amant et ça évidemment
c'est pas fait pour vous déplaire pas
seulement un bon amant car il y en a
beaucoup mais je sais que tu ne sais pas
ça mais
mais il n'avait pas peur de me dire j'ai
besoin de toi mais les femmes aiment ça
bien sûr oui on aime être nécessaire a
dit m'a jamais fait quoi que j'étais
nécessaire probablement parce que je
n'étais pas là c'est clair parce que je
n'étais pas bardot vous êtes vous êtes
vraiment aujourd'hui extrêmement
extrêmement lucide sur tout et très sage
en même temps je suis très sage presque
ça non c'est vrai alors ça en blaguant
en 1991 donc ted turner vous épouser
mais un mois plus tard
vous découvrez que qu'il a d'autres
femmes alors là évidemment vous commencé
à lui faire un peu des scènes veut dire
que c'est pas possible qu'il ait
d'autres d'autres aventures après avoir
battu avec le téléphone dans la voiture
voilà oui c'était dans quel film c'est
justement tout en ne battant je me suis
dit j'ai jamais vu ça dans un film
et là vous le gardez quand même pendant
sept ans il est resté sept ans sans
bouger quoi
oui n'ont pas pris tu attends voilà vous
séparer en 99 à ce qu'on l'a vous avez
62 ans devant marié là haut je vois pas
non un amant peut-être mettra j'aimerais
eh oui
m
c'est dur
on va faire un petit ardi view un deux
trois quarts
jane oui thierry vous pensez à quoi là
en ce moment là le lie à
quand vous regardez le matin dans votre
miroir vous vous dites quoi
non donc je me dis bon alors il ya des
rides mais il faut ne me me devient ami
ami avec mes rides un oui je ne veux pas
les enlever
il faut donner un image culturelle à des
femmes d'un certain âge à hollywood tout
les femmes se ressemblent
j'aime pas du tout ça loisel oui oui l
épée cure et tout ça vous êtes
magnifique vous dire s'ils en ont
vraiment mais c'est beaucoup je me sens
très bien j'ai de très belles vraiment
merci ça vient de l'intérieur
votre plus belle histoire d'amour c'est
laquelle ils sont tous les trois très
différents et puis les âmes entre d'être
entre temps mais je crois que c'était
avec ted turner si il aurait pu changer
avec moi c'est ça qui aurait duré je
l'aimais beaucoup je laime toujours ami
avec lui oui la mito maiden aussi oui
oui oui
avant sa mort avec vadim aussi quand
avez vous pleuré pour la dernière fois à
jane ouragan katrina
oui j'ai pleuré de hay heureusement que
pendant cinq jours il y avait rien comme
aide pour ces gens est ce que les
américains ont compris maintenant oui
mais que l'argent qui était envoyé en
irak pour faire la guerre aux irakiens
ils feraient mieux de s'en occuper
je crois que oui de plus en plus oui
d'accord tant mieux si moins de choses
oui vous changeriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique
gm en effet j'aurais j'aimerais bien
tomber amoureuse encore une fois on sait
pouvoir si je vais vraiment changé tant
que je crois on ne peut pas savoir si on
vit avec un chien vous comprenez ce que
je veux
tu vas tu as ta d'hollywood ouais je
vais me lancer dans cinéma grande
distribution et ils vont te causer
meilleur ici je vais dire va
si votre ville et et arrêtons à l'avion
nous ce qui d'abord s'il veut de vie
était à refaire qu'est-ce que vous
changeriez jeu j'aurais parenté ma fille
je t'ai pas très doué en tant que maire
pour masquer sa ça s'arrange maintenant
droit il s'était jeté mieux c'était
mieux oui oui alors si vous resté que
vingt-quatre heures avis vous feriez
quoi je jouais avec mes petits-enfants
oui malcom qui a 16 ans et vivent à quai
à trois ans qu'est ce que la vie vous a
appris jane qui font toujours rester
intéressé c'est beaucoup plus important
que d'être intéressant
comment
comment aimeriez-vous mourir dans mon
lit entouré par les gens qui m'aiment on
va y aller
non mais
l'accès
et je vais te dire
les vrais ma pièce
eh bien
dans la voiture je relève
tout seul ah bon les corrections de ne
rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
il m'était impossible eux